I was out on it I just want be better
than yesterday it's important man I know
and I I could if I get this same amount
of money and run and go away I
would so for you your in like like it's
almost like if I can get this get to
this certain goal whatever it may be
you're comfortable with just
disappearance
for sure for sure once all this behind
me mhm move to Europe or some
[__] once the legal stuff is is out of
your way we might not hear from you all
this put behind me oh you going to hear
from me but we W know where you
are I think you always know where I'm at
too
okay is it been it's been what 3 years
now since you've been dealing with the
current situation almost three yeah is
it wearing on you yet man I'm sure at
times it's got to be tough to kind of
just feel confined I mean obviously you
have a nice place but it's still yeah
but I got it better than I got it better
than so many people for sure who are
stuck in their apartment we stuck oh I
stuck inside a [__] City going to the
club every
week yeah the club man I don't get it
anymore I got every I got I got
everybody to approve of
who I love and who I like to be
around that's important they come when I
call mhm um now I don't wake up in no
sale now you have a beautiful property
man yeah you got beautiful animals you
got beautiful children your wife's here
you got a made man hey we lit could hit
that trail and go all the way behind
this
mountain it's crazy to see
like the things that like you know your
environment changes you it teaches you
things like for you like do you feel
like you've kind of adopted like being
like an Outdoorsman a bit cuz I feel
like you you got to kind of embrace
nature if you're I want to really get
into it like I want to learn how to feel
my backpack up on my own go up in the
mountain start a fire cook something eat
it come back like survive yeah you ever
watch those shows on Netflix where
they're naked and they have to survive
in the middle of nowhere I I I glanced
at them a couple times it's intriguing
cuz you'll see how they start fires you
see how they like they'll catch fish
they'll I mean no that's so so you might
that that might be a nice little side
mission for for you just to kind
of you know hey we're going to go to the
forest for a day we're going to Camp
we're going to we're going to we're
going to catch our
food I had a bobcat jump out on us uh up
there one day a
bobcat what
happened did it run off man that [__]
that [__] tried to get to the can now
that bit L tried to run into it it was
me and
D did it run off did it survive I look
to see where it went all we see was it
cing out the bus i' be worried about
bears bro have you seen any bears up
here no I really think I saw a big print
before so those bears are the ones cuz
they'll come in the house to look for
food I hope that don't never happen have
you ever watched the that Leonardo
DiCaprio movie Revenant where
he gets attacked by a bear from behind
and he just gets [__] destroyed no it
made me scared the Bears forever I'm an
animal guy I would I would like to pet a
bear one day you know I'm scared of
their speed yeah ain't no getting away
from this [__] the speed and the force
ain't No Getting Away man man n for sure
dude I just think it's fast like a goat
cart